you
[Music]
so welcome to the probable algorithms in
machine learning session I hope you'll
see a happy mixture of theory and
machine learning in this session we have
three speakers we are glad to have as
our first speaker Sean Cassidy who's on
the University of Washington computer
science faculty he holds the data
science chair there he has been at
Microsoft before that and University of
Pennsylvania so here is shunk thanks
Ravi and thanks to fatigue for inviting
me so it's great to be back at MSR so
I'm going to be speaking about some work
in a line of work related to optimal
statistical estimation and these are
problems with regards to how we discover
a hidden structure in our data and the
problems which I think underlie many of
the challenges we face in a variety of
scientific and engineering settings ok
and you know you can think of some
problem where you have a speech signal
and you have lots of data of audio
waveforms and we'd like to discover say
phone concepts like phonemes or
underlying structure in our data in an
automated way ok but many of the
settings we have are discrete and
understood by giving an example where we
have our data in account format so let's
look at an example of say from something
like maybe natural language processing
where we have a cockney tricks of
co-occurrences awards ok so so think of
a matrix where on one axis represents
one word and another axis represents say
another set of words and we put a dot in
this table if words I and J co-occur
okay so many of the data we have a look
like this it can be an integer rather
than just a dot and
and now our job is to try to figure out
some structure in this data okay and
this is what it looks like but what we'd
like is our data to be presented in this
format here all I've done is taken this
matrix and I've commuted the rows and
the columns to make the structure a
little more visible okay so and
basically there's a grouping of the
words you might think of these as topics
of which things co-occur together okay
so the underlying problem here is
basically you know in this very naive
model its to sort of a swap around the
rows and columns so the underlying
structure becomes more clear okay and
nobody tells us to this grouping and
you know many of the these latent
variable models we that that we seek to
activate in practice problems like this
are the underlying sub problem okay so
as if questions I'll define the model a
little more precisely but at a high
level this is a this is kind of what the
data look like okay so you know how do
we learn some of these latent variable
models you know there's a lot of
heuristics out there like k-means e/m in
in terms of this natural language
processing setting it's sort of related
to some of these embedding methods that
I'll touch upon them briefly now with
regards to to theory there's a number of
us that have been working on sort of
provable methods for estimating hidden
structure and by provable what what do
we mean here we mean we get data we'd
like to say discover topics or
estimating hmm and you know the short
answer for a line of work by a number a
number of people including people in the
audience is that for a variety of these
models we have computationally efficient
algorithms to estimate
the underlying structure okay so this
means I'm just going to give you a table
of this form and I want you to do the
grouping and I want you to do this
efficiently without kind of trying all
possibilities and there are in fact
computationally efficient algorithms do
this but you know there's a difference
between provable and practical so many
of these these methods we developed in
theory they work fine if a sample size
is very large okay and you know so the
style of guarantee that if we have
enough data then in a relatively small
amount of computation time we'll recover
the hidden structure okay but you know
what we care about input is that you
know I don't necessarily really care
about just being provable I want
scalable algorithms that work well in
practice okay I'm going to argue in a
moment that in fact many of these these
algorithms actually are not going to be
effective in practical settings that we
care about in a variety of disciplines
okay but first let me give you some
insight as to you know what the basic
ideas okay I'll do it okay I'll give the
basic idea of these algorithms with a
pretty actually a really practical
algorithm it's one which I think works
works pretty well out of the box I think
in in some regimes its competitive with
some of these kind of newer network
based embeddings but it's super simple
and robust ok so suppose we have a
corpus of natural language okay and I
want to figure out how to group words
together and I have a word like
philosophy and maybe I have a word like
topology okay I have no idea if how
close they are and the words themselves
are completely disparate right the word
red and green they have nothing to do
with each other just they're different
symbols okay but what you could do is
forever
we would in your corpus try to predict
the word that follows it okay so for
every word W let Phi of W be the word
that follows it okay and the idea is
words like red and green even though the
words themselves are different they're
going to proceed very similar words okay
so the idea is the step one is first you
take your words build a prediction of
what follows it okay then what you're
going to do is cluster the mappings of
what follows the woods so for every word
you have a vector of what types of
things follow it then you cluster those
vectors okay so this is a way to get
groupings or embeddings of of words it
works it looks really quite well in many
different settings and it's extremely
easy to implement and this in fact in
papers arguing that these newer new
network methods are basically doing the
same thing they're doing some kind of
means you can implement this idea with a
singular value decomposition it's
actually sort of related to some work
proceeded in his master's thesis which
also works well in the setting on on
Brown clustering okay so this is a very
intuitive way to try to learn word
embeddings by just trying to figure out
what words follow some word and then
group and do the grouping based on that
so the problem with this method and many
others and and both both in practice and
in theory is that in practice the
distribution over words are very heavy
tailed okay so this is true not just in
natural language processing it's true
with a lot of data we have that's coming
from the sciences for example in health
care data in genomics data the events of
interest are really not going to occur
very many times but the data we have is
basically tables of zero
okay and and when we'd like to
understand this hidden structure and say
how to group things together we really
faced with this problem that our data
are very very sparse and in in this
regime many of these these methods you
know these methods I mentioned actually
don't work so in particular this table
here in practice we're not going to get
a table that's as dense as this it's
basically going to be much of zeroes
okay and and I'd argue that you know why
we care about provable learning here is
that in this regime it's actually like
we know from simple theoretical examples
we know that algorithms fail and getting
this right is actually very difficult
and in the intuitive reason is that you
know as our datasets grow we're going to
see more new events in new words so
effectively in many settings even though
we're in this court in court big data
regime it's still effectively a small
sample size because we're seeing more
and more new words okay so you know in
other regimes that isn't the case but
many of the scientific disciplines we
really are in this small sample regime
because the size of a vocabulary is very
large and as we get data we are just
going to see more and more new words
okay and and and this is the question
how do we learn in this regime when our
data are very sparse and and these
questions are really fundamentally
related to some of these ideas in sparse
random graph theory where you have some
random graph you believe maybe there's
some communities in it maybe to in the
simplest case and you want to discover
them but the key point is this graph is
very very sparse that there's not you
know the edges aren't kind of everywhere
so so this is the the basic challenge
we're trying to address and and and the
key is we'd like to do estimation with a
sample size that grows linear in the
vocabulary size because if I if I really
need a very dense matrix for an
algorithm to the work the algorithm to
work is just not going to be applicable
in many different settings particular
like in these healthcare settings and
some of these natural language
processing settings for the real words
okay so I'm really just going to try to
go through a toy example to show you how
we can connect some of these ideas in
graph theory to to these hidden
structured models so let's start with
the simplest model this is a two topic
model so think of a setting where we're
going to get a collection of documents
and every document is about one topic
okay and and I'm going to make a
co-occurrence matrix by I'm going to
look I'm going to try to estimate which
words co-occur together
okay so let's not let's suppose those
two topics in the world so maybe math
and philosophy and P is a distribution
of a math words
Q is a distribution of philosophy words
so P I is the probability of would I
under say the Matt topic and a Qi is the
probability war die under the philosophy
topic okay we're going to say the joint
probability of seeing two words together
so say a word like maybe topology and
des cartes
we're going to model it as first we flip
a coin and decide which topic it is we
have a half a half and then we sample
the two words under that topic okay so
we're assuming this co-occurrence matrix
has a particular rank two structure so
the questions about the model
okay so another way to think of this is
this is the model for how we assembling
that count matrix so we're going to put
a dot in that matrix with the
probability P I plus CI x pj plus qy x
QJ okay and this means that the expected
matrix we see is this rank two matrix
which is TP transpose to ski Q transpose
okay and this is really a sub problem
for estimating things like topic models
hidden Markov models Lda and community
section so we can understand this well
the claim is this generalizes to many
other of these richer latent variable
settings so so the question is how do we
estimate a P and Q okay and it's a rank
2 matrix so we can't just do the SVD
because these are probability vectors
are P and Q but suppose we know this by
grab matrix this M by n matrix for now
okay so what can we do well the first
point is that okay so
our goal is to try to estimate this
model with samples okay and I'm going to
sketch an algorithm which estimates this
model with a sample size that's linear
in the size of the in the number of in
the vocabulary size which is M so we've
got M words in the vocabulary and note
that this matrix is of size M squared
okay so we're going to try to estimate
this with linear and M samples okay and
that's the crucial aspect of this
because this means that the number of
entries we're actually going to see is
is a vanishing fraction of this matrix
okay so and the subproblem is really
relevant to many problems and as I
mentioned in graph theory and community
detection okay so so here's the basic
idea of how we can recover this matrix
okay so note we can decompose this
matrix in the basically a matrix in
terms of P plus Q and P minus Q okay and
P plus Q is easy to estimate from the
data because that's just the marginal
distribution over words in our language
right so to estimate P plus Q this is
trivial I just look and see how often
was the car okay and then I get 1/2 P
plus 1/2 Q ok and and now what do we
need to learn we just need to learn the
difference of these two vectors okay and
so if I had enough data here would be
the algorithm which is first I estimate
the marginal distribution of awards in
the language then I estimate this by
gram matrix and if I had enough data
I'll estimate this a near to exactly
then I subtract off the marginal
distribution so that's this Rolo
transpose and what's left is a rank one
matrix which is of the form P minus Q P
minus Q transpose which is the
difference
okay then I just do an SVD on that
because it's rank one and then I know
the difference right so basically I'm I
first estimates the sum then I take my
by gram matrix manipulate it to be rank
one and then I estimate the difference
okay and then I can use those to find P
and Q okay and this is very related to
that sort of algorithm ention by Daniel
Hsu based on co-occurrence statistics
and you know many of these techniques
are similar in spirit to this one okay
so the reason this algorithm will not
work is due to the fact that we're going
to need a super linear number of samples
to get these matrices accurate accurate
enough for this algorithm to succeed
okay and basically we really need to see
the rare words many many times before
this algorithm will succeed and the
intuition is that just by chance a
certain events are going to occur more
often they should okay so what will
happen is there'll be certain dense rows
in this matrix that are a bit more dense
than they should be and then when you do
the SVD operation it will actually not
succeed okay and there's arguments that
these issues come up even with even in
with other methods like if use natural
language processing settings people look
at these newer Network methods and it
looks like they're getting the
distributions of the rail words pretty
incorrect okay so even in these two
examples we know naive methods really
will watch the derail words okay so so
how do we fix this
okay so the main result here is an
algorithm which
can actually learn both P and Q which is
what we care about with a sample size
that is linear in in the vocabulary size
okay so this is in the total variation
distance but the basic idea is that you
can estimate this this P hat when you
have when your sample size n is about M
okay and and suppose P and Q are
somewhat separated because if the topics
are the same obviously you can't do
anything okay so suppose they're
different by some Delta and total
variation distance okay so so what's the
basic idea and it's a pretty intuitive
algorithm so so here's here's the basic
idea of the algorithm and I think it
actually gives us reasonable heuristics
for a wider class of algorithms okay so
suppose we these two topics have some
separation between them and they have to
because if they weren't separated there
would be no problem here okay so this
means there has to exist some set of
words which are more likely under the
mat topic than the philosophy topic and
it has to exist some set of words which
are more likely under the philosophy
topic than the math topic and and by
this I mean significantly more likely so
you know words like topology gauss women
might be very heavy words in the math
topic which i occur often and words like
you know maybe decart
epistemology Saltzer might occur more in
the philosophy topic okay and if you
lump these together they both are you
know I have a reasonable chance of
occurring and they occur significantly
more often in one topic than the other
okay so suppose so let's call this an
anchor set so these are sets of words
they don't have to be disjoint because
someone like decart is a philosopher and
a mathematician but suppose we knew a
set of words which are mostly about math
and a set of words which are mostly
about philosophy okay how would we solve
this problem okay it turns out the
pretty natural thing to do is let's look
at the core occurrences of our words
with these anchor sets okay
so we have a set of sort of Matthew
words and we have a set of philosophy
words for every word let's look at the
probability they occur with these anchor
sets okay and in the claim is this is
easy to estimate because these anchor
sets occur often right this this matrix
is really so there's bigram matrix now
is really a 2 by n matrix because I'm
going to try to estimate the probability
of every word occurring with with what
with these anchor sets so the anchor set
what I'm really going to do is to lump
all of these words together into one
kind of meta wood okay and we can look
at under this model what's the
probability that some word occurs with
the anchor set a well it's going to be
just half P of W times half P of a where
P of a is the probability under a plus
1/2 Q of W half Q of a ok so this
immediately gives us an algorithm that
if I knew these anchor sets and their
probabilities all I'm going to do is
figure out for every word how often it
co-occurs with these sets and then just
solve a set of linear equations but in
words that means I'm just going to kind
of balance balance these two
probabilities so if I take a word like
the cart and I want to figure out how
much mass and velocity is I'm just going
to look at the co-occurrence of this
word with these anchor words and kind of
the assignment of Dakota P and Q
appropriately okay and that amounts to
just solving this linear system to to
figure out to figure out the peas and
the Q's and the reason this is very easy
to do is I'm no longer looking at this
gigantic M squared matrix I'm really
taking one one side of this matrix and
collapsing it okay and and it's a very
easy algorithm because for every word
we're going to solve this system
separately this is again if we knew this
anchor set in a sense this is intuitive
right because if someone has grounded me
and given me a ton of stuff about math
already and if someone has grounded me
and has given me a lot of frequently
occurring words about philosophy it's
almost like I have crude labels and then
I can just bootstrap off of that okay
and this algorithm you can convince
yourself clearly as linear size and the
intuition is that I'm just using a
matrix of size 2 by M okay so that is
really going to be a very dense matrix
and and intuitively that's why you can
really get down to this this linear
sample size okay but you know in a sense
that the question is we've kind of
pushed the problem now into learning
these anchor sets okay and and this is
the part where I think I'll defer to the
paper and we'll have a forthcoming
version coming out hopefully coming out
soon but I think it's a problem that
many of the algorithms really do fail in
practice when we when we have our data
with lots of zeros and you know this
algorithm is really two parts which is
how do we get off the ground which is
just how do we roughly figure out what
math and philosophy are and then once we
have those we can definitely piece it
together
with the second phase okay and sometimes
there might be other information which
which will tell us about mounts and
philosophy but if we don't have that I
would say the details are really how do
we even just get off the ground okay and
and to get off the ground I'll just
sketch this out
the difficulty here is that in real data
just by chance some words are going to
occur more often than others okay and
this problem it basically makes it
extremely difficult to to get off the
ground because when you try some
eigenvector based method somehow
everything just falls on these heavy
words and it seems like many other
algorithms suffer from this problem and
the way this has been addressed in sort
of the math community is you have to
have some way of roughly figuring out
which things are occurring more often by
chance and throwing them away okay so if
this matrix was very homogenous meaning
[Music]
you know if the matrix we had all of the
rows will roughly had equal mass then
what you would do is throw out the rows
and columns which were very very heavy
and then try to run run the algorithm
based on that the difficulty in these
realistic settings is in addition to
this matrix being mostly zeros it's also
very very imbalanced so it's tricky to
even get a guess as to which rows are
occurring more often by chance and due
to you know in terms of a sketch the
part of the first phase is a scheme to
kind of detect
which things occurring more occurring
more often by chance and zeroing that
stuff out and we know from probability
theory that these sort of events really
will occur and they do actually cause
lots of problems with with previous
algorithms okay so so the basic idea of
this algorithm is phase one we're going
to figure out this anchor set and there
were going to be very careful about how
we do an SVD operation which is we're
going to try to basically run one of
these spectral schemes and throw away
rows and columns that seem unlikely and
then phase two once we have the anchor
sets phase two is easy okay so I'll just
end by sort of mentioning that there are
many questions we face where we have
these count matrices as we get to richer
settings they become count tensors and
we really need to figure out how to
estimate in the sparse regime and even
in this two topic case it's actually
pretty challenging to get things right
and this isn't a problem I'd argue that
is just an issue in theory because
because in this sort of big data regime
in these settings we're effectively rd8
as effectively sparse
okay so in the remaining minute I have
I'll just give a plug for something very
different which is that you know the
last year a bunch of colleagues at u-dub
and I have created a label dataset in
music this is very different just a
shameless plug for a cool new data set
and if the data set where we have sort
of a few hundred classical music
recordings where we've annotated and
mussed up where every note starts and
stopped
we found an automated way to do this
so if you go to my website or just
search for music net or John's John
Dickson's website the datasets freely
available
it's got like 30 plus hours of real
recordings and what it looks like is for
every instrument and note in the data
set it'll tell you when it starts and
when it ends like up to a millisecond
range okay and and it's a exciting data
set because it gives us a way to do
machine learning in a very different
domain so it's just a teaser for
something different okay so so sort of
discussed some questions with regard to
information theoretic limits for
learning sort of a two-factor hidden
variable model and I think the one
algorithmic inside I want to mention
here is that these questions really do
connect to some questions
you know probabilities have been
studying for quite some time now which
is how do we discover structure in these
sparse random graphs and and the key
connection is that this subproblem is
very relevant to many other problems
that that are going to be coming up in
sparse source estimation questions and
these are questions are relevant because
the naive algorithms we have really are
not estimating effectively in in this
boss regime so thanks and this is a
joint work with a number of talented
colleagues greg valiant we Hong Kong and
chin chin Wang
a very quick question yes okay so Julie
Holcomb our University of Illinois hi hi
champagne and I was wondering so in
standard language modeling like you
would use something like Couture and
smoothing yes but which seems sort of
ISIL and spirit fighting that you you
basically bucket your you know your
counts right you could you say bit more
about the relation so in a sense like
these this deep loading paper I
mentioned to some of these methods when
you're coming up with language models
and doing deep loading models you
actually use these good-turing estimates
in the tails of the distribution now
here the difficulty is that good-turing
estimates are used when everything is
observed so so in a sense like if I see
the word York five times in my data set
when you always precedes it then there's
a good chance that New York goes
together because whereas if I see the
word York and a different word precedes
it every time then I probably don't have
a good idea of its distribution now the
ideas for good touring estimates really
can't be utilized here because we aren't
actually observing the the hidden topic
so in a sense if we could observe the
hidden topic then we could directly
figure out how to do the smoothing in a
sense you could argue what these are
these random graph theory results how we
smooth count matrices when there's
hidden structure because we don't
actually you know we don't actually
observe everything and I think this is a
you know really the right question is
how do we basically smooth our data to
get good estimates when there's really
hidden structure in it but yeah so
that's a great question thank you thanks
[Applause]
so I want the interviews first a problem
related to topic modeling but it's much
simpler so it's good to see that first
topic modeling is of that is of the same
genre so you're given a matrix with
non-negative entries and the question is
to factor it into two matrices a tall
and skinny one and you know the right
dimensions there for C but they have
been on negative if I didn't tell non
negativity it's a simple traditional
problem but non negativity is hard and
with a lot of applications topic
modeling is of this genre so it's nice
to remember this picture I'm going to
introduce tropic modeling you have lots
of documents we'll see that the largest
corpus will deal with 100 million
documents there are K unknown topics I
don't tell you the topics you have to
find them the document as well as the
topic we just go by word frequencies is
the bag of voice representation we throw
away order we are just given how many
times each word occurs normalized to one
sum to one your job is to find the
topics that's too hard you can show NP
hardness and it's in general very hard
so the way out of this that one way out
of this is to assume a generative model
a stochastic model that generated the
topic model that makes the problem
little easier because you don't have the
worst case scenario to deal with and
that was probably the most used model
was LD a late into the Excel allocation
it is the most you smarter not walk by
blinding and Jordan what they got their
model says is for each topic I'm going
fast because I assume some of you or
many of you are familiar with these
things but I want to just recap them for
each document i generate weights on each
topic and then I take the weighted
combination of the topics topics or
vectors so I take the weighted
combination of out frequencies and then
I generate words in the document
independently of each other one try one
word one file one word with these
weighted combination as probabilities
right I'll give you a example in a
minute it's a nice model and so on so
forth there's a but the
refers to you'll see what is here the
model way when I made the slide six
months ago and I was getting very
worried that we'll be out of date but
apparently it's not so it still is too
current okay so what you're given is
just the term document matrix right so I
give you the 10 to the six documents for
each document I give you the word count
I have nicely ordered the words but they
are not given to you in ordered way they
are given alphabetically or something so
the lower the election occurs nine
percent of the time nine percent of the
words of election in the first document
eleven percent is put in and so on and
so forth right now what you have to find
and I don't give you this is that matrix
with three topics the topics have
weights for words they add a column
value to one if you want to do a sanity
check while you're not listening but
post-facto
after I have done the job and found
those I can name them that's the names
and topics are not given to you so the
first one might be called politics right
and since the word is name is not given
the second one might either be called
weather or Seattle although that second
part is wrong now this very nice weather
now the hidden model might have
generated the documents as follows it
has the topic matrix and says I take
point three times the politics 0.4 times
weather 0.3 times
I'm sorry 0.3 times whether they're 0.4
times the second topic and that
combination gives me those numbers and
they generate the first document from
those probably with those probabilities
now you see that the counts are quite
different from the probabilities and
that's typical we do very few words
generated so the variance is enormously
high that's indeed a problem with these
models that the weighted combination of
the probability vector are the
probability vector and the document may
differ a lot there's a lot of variance
right so this is the numerical picture
but perhaps a better picture will come
in a minute it's geometric but before I
go there I
want to step back and sort of tell you a
little bit what water what we mean by
the title of the session and Shaam
already talked a little bit about this
so machine learning has studied these
problems the emphasis on machine
learning is is the model and also simple
heuristics to try to learn the model so
the algorithms or simple heuristics they
work on many benchmarks but they
sometimes fail in theory we would like
to develop algorithms which have several
properties and I won't list them in
order except to say it be paper and the
word I'm going to talk about sort of
combines the best of these it didn't
with a series of papers and then this is
what we got it's not that it happened
overnight
we'll have empirically verifiable
assumptions and I'll tell you in a
minute what that means and we want
proven time and error bounds so the word
probable refers to bounce on running
time and error right and it turns out
that our current argument also scales up
in addition to being proven and it
scales up to this is the size now I want
to note that this is on a single box
right I mean you could do many bigger
things if you but we wanted to do it on
a single box and we can do basically six
billion tokens means words six six
billion tomans write the word probable I
want to stress again because there was
something we want to get through so if
data was generated by unknown model the
algorithm should probably approximately
find the generating model the reason for
saying this is this is unsupervised
learning and in unsupervised learning we
do not have a notion of the correct
answer right and therefore proving that
you're close to the correct answer is
difficult unless you assume there was
actually a model and now we have to
prove that I get that hidden model and
we also want to polynomial time bounce
and here's a bunch of references
so I guess sort of the theory is paper
or non-negative matrix factorization
that we had in 2012 had topic modeling
as
case then our organizer actually did it
for topic modeling making certain
assumptions and I will tell you the
assumptions in a minute they are part of
the model there's the paper the charm
already talked about tensor based
methods and what part of the talk a
precursor to this talk is a paper which
was annexed and of course the
scalability is something that will will
stress this is a picture I want you to
remember me you may forget all the you
don't forget all the stuff that I said
so far
please remember this picture so here is
a picture right we are sitting if there
are B words these 50,000 let's say this
is a picture in 50,000 dimensions I'm
trying to capture that by a picture on
this on the slide right so there are
three topics here these numbers
correspond to the numbers we had in the
example but you don't have to remember
the numbers the three topics of the
corners of a triangle more generally if
simplex and the hidden model generates
the process which are rated combinations
of topics right the topic of the corners
weighted they're convex combinations all
the crosses are inside the triangle the
economic combinations I don't tell you
the crosses I observe only the circles
the circles are actual documents so with
this probability vector I generated this
document now you notice that some of the
circles or many of the circles actually
can be outside the triangle they are not
constrained to be convex combinations
and indeed the variance is so high this
picture is not quite correct things are
very far apart okay and so this again
just sitting in 50,000 dimensions I give
you the circles and I want you to find
the corners the three corners the three
corners of the topics that's what I want
you to find so here comes the departure
from existing models that we have to
make based on empirical observations and
there's a little Theory there so I'll
tell you what is itself existing models
all assume that the topic vectors are
quite distinct from each other it
doesn't make sense to have
topics that are similar that they are
distinct from each other mathematically
that translates to being linearly
independent and they put very
independent linearly independent could
just mean barely but it's not good
enough so assume that they are quite
linearly independent if that assumption
were true and we want to scale up to
let's say 5000 topics as the document
copper scales up we want to scale up
number of topics as well we should have
that the rank of the data matrix is at
least 5000 but rank is an observable
quantity I must say that even though
this is not rocket science to say rank
is observable let's check if our models
rank and the empirical rank or roughly
similar this has not been done before
but it's a simple idea so let's check
the rank of data and see if it is that
high and the answer is not I'll give you
a little plot on the next slide so we
are not going to be able to empirically
justify having a high rank where the
topics are independent high number of
topics of the topics are independent so
we have to depart from independence so
our model first assumes that there's a
small number of linearly independent
basic topics those are the corners of
the triangle three of them again I'll
show you another picture and we actually
have many more topics which are not just
the corners but convex combinations of
the two basic vectors so we use these
complex combinations to get many more
topics so here's a picture about the
rank if maybe you all see how do you
quantify the rank singular values those
who are familiar you know what they are
but I won't define them the singular
values in indeed drop off quite fast in
these two data sets we've done other
data sets as well so you cannot assume
very high rank in some essential sense
so here is a picture of our model now we
call the triangle was the same as what
we had that was the old traditional
model now instead of just the triangle
topics we now have six topics okay and
they are on the edges of their each of
these in the convex combination of these
basic topics and
we actually call them appropriately edge
topics you can have higher confounders
combinations as phase topics but right
now edge topics and if there are too
many points near the corners right then
this gives you a tighter description of
a tighter model that this that explains
the data okay that's all I will say
intuitively for the model I mean the
details or the and the paper but this is
all a say so we define models with large
number of dependent topics which are
complex combinations of the basic topics
so our models as in any model the
general problem is hard has some
assumptions the first assumption is that
each topic is a set of catch words catch
words should have high frequency in the
topic compared to in other topics so we
saw Putin could be a catch word with the
word politics for the topic politics is
at higher frequency there than weather
right so it replaces an assumption which
is much stronger in a sense of anchor
words the anchor words assumption the
difference is illustrated again just by
an example here let's say the word
homerun occurs the anchor word
assumption would be the word homerun
occurs exclusively anchor words are
exclusive to one topic and also high
frequency every 10th word is that
particular word instead our assumption
assumes with multiple words which are
have higher frequency the topic than
other topics but also not a single but
the total frequency is at least 110
which is more reasonable
these are empirically verified
assumptions and I won't go into the
verification assumption to I do want to
get the assumptions through because they
define the model so assumption 2 is like
each topic as a dominant top each
document of the dominant topic dominant
doesn't mean weight is 0.9 it means
point 2 or higher whether 100 topics
point 2 is a fairly high thing compared
to the average and other topics it's
less but they're also going to be as
there's going to be
pure documents there are a small
fraction of documents which are purely
on each topic this you need to identify
the corners if there's nobody near the
corner you'll never see the corner all
three assumptions are empirically
verified they probably hold in the old
model so this model is a proper
generalization it it holds an Lda model
that's mathematically proven and we also
make some other technical assumptions we
also assume a stochastic model and then
use SVD as a as a big part of our tool
and I want to go a little bit into what
happens with this video is a bit of a
story here in a 92 de me and others
formulated what's called latent semantic
indexing using SVD and that was pre
topic model paper by one of our next
speaker and this co-author actually
proved that LSI does two topic modeling
probably if there are certain certain
strong conditions that every document is
purely on one topic but then people
somehow assumed they converse holds
which didn't prove or didn't even
mention but SVD got a bad rap and it
said people assumed the SVD kit does not
help when there are multiple topics and
in a way Lda one of the one of the
motivations for Lda was this in fact
I've mentioned in the paper and then
there are papers by people that I've
coated with other papers but they call
it beyond SVD to me you know somehow SVD
got a bad rap but here is really comes
back we do three simple steps with
threshold do SVD and cluster and then
find catch weights I'm going to
illustrate these steps by pictures again
so if you don't remember this it's
alright this is a picture it looks very
similar to the picture that chomp showed
you I promise you I didn't borrow this
picture and turn it upside down because
he had it the other way but but it is it
is a picture I made up before I saw it
stock so here's a picture so I've taken
what I've done
here is I have rearranged the words to
get catch word for topic one topic to
topic two in that order
I've rearranged the documents the
columns to get dominant topic one
documents with dominant topic one two
three and so on after I do the
rearrangement this is not the way it's
given I do the rearrangement the
diagonal should have heavy blocks
ideally it should be only block
diagonals then will be very nice but it
doesn't happen there's still a lot of
smudge we do something called fresh
holding fresh holding just refers to for
each word we find a threshold and set to
zero if the frequency is below set to
one if it's about okay section is more
complicated what to simplify matters
that's what we do and you see that
threshold e cleans up the picture a lot
okay I want to make another remark
there's a lot of black stuff these are
things that are not catch words for any
topic this is typical a good fraction of
the words or not catch words for any
topic so that's a tale that Shawn was
also referring to you've got to get the
tail right and that's let's in fact a
complicated problem that make makes our
life a bit harder so we develop an
algorithm to find the correct threshold
they are different for different words
and then threshold at that and we do SVD
and cluster I won't again go into the
details except to go over this picture
so here are three clusters in this
picture we all know that we do K means
came in structuring has a problem that
if you started badly you're sunk and
here I've shown you a good start and a
bad start a good start is when you have
one point in each cluster at the start
you your home a bad start is two points
in one cluster you can convince yourself
you'll never escape from that you're in
trouble
if you started badly okay so we use SVD
to start right and that's based on some
earlier results now again let's go back
to the picture and see what clustering
has bought us this is our old picture
right clustering has drawn these thick
red lines I've got all documents which
have done in topic one two and three
right
I've crusted them out right now is this
good enough normally we would have just
taken the average of each cluster the
mean of each cluster says the cluster
Center that's no good because we don't
want somebody in the middle of that
region we want the corners right so the
difficulty is finding the corners real
outlays okay so we cannot do what we do
in clustering we have to do this so
here's what we do to find I'm going to
run over that fast in several steps the
algorithm we first find the catch words
for each topic and we do that by taking
certain fractals so don't worry about
the details we find catch weights and
then we find the pure documents
documents purely on each topic by taking
exactly those documents which are very
high total catch word frequency all of
this has to be proved and we prove that
in the paper these things knew what what
we clink they do and then once you found
the pure documents they are near the
corners I'm just taking the average that
will give you the corners this is so far
only finding the basic topics now we
have to find the topics on the edges now
this is intuitively to be thought of as
a primary subject or a primary topic and
a secondary topic so we want to find the
two top topics for each document how do
we do that for each document we take the
basic topic basic primary topic and the
basic secondary topic has the two
heaviest topics in frequency and we take
the average there is some fuss so you
have to worry about things being large
enough then you take the average that
gives you the edge topics so that
actually in somebody completes the
algorithm I'm going to spend a couple of
minutes on empirical results so let me
step back as in all unsupervised
learning problems there is no gold
standard for quality because we do not
know the correct answer right we cannot
claim to know the correct answers so
here are the measures that have been
used in the literature and I'm going to
use them likelihood is a standard
measure is how likely is it that your
model
generated the data the higher it is the
better the models but you have to learn
right topic coherence measures as it
says that you take the top forward you
found for each topic and see if they
co-occur a lot in the whole corpus if
they did you found perhaps good set of
words reconstruction error this is what
we want to prove in theory which is does
the topic model constructed from a
finite number of samples converge to the
perceived count truth you cannot do this
for real corpus because you don't know
the reek you don't know what model
generated it
we will sweep that problem under the rug
for now but it can be dealt with and we
compare with light as the aid and I say
so Lda have gone through is a very nice
algorithmic development like Lda is in
some sense of state of thought the
Markov chain that is run in early this
in in this algorithm is much improved
and really nice clever ideas have gone
into this so we compare it with like Lda
on some standard corpus and then we give
you the results and so our algorithm the
conclusions are mostly better than
likely not always and we'll see the
tables the data effects we tried justice
Isis so a tokens means the number of
total number of words nnz is number of
non-zeros which is a number of distinct
words it's a bit smaller for the largest
one is six billion words on the whole
right so let's stare at this both face
is supposed to be better and I'll is our
algorithm and Lda is the like early
thing let's see so we are okay I wanted
to point out the case where we are not
better which is Wikipedia right the
topic coherences but it's not
occurrences log of something so it's
negative so the higher the better still
so they're like LD is better we have an
explanation for that but let's not go
into that otherwise we will see that in
general
we are better now this is done with K
not is a number of basic topics the
corners number of corners is one hundred
thousand and two thousand the number of
total number of topics the edge topics
or 10k 20k and fifty okay so this is a
picture to show that our algorithm are
rather than use of sampling that
sub-samples the corpus not at the outset
if you have to use the whole corpus for
the entire algorithm but for most of the
algorithm we run on a subsample this is
showing that the subsampling does not
destroy quality empirically so we did
this 100 percent and then with ten
percent and we see that the quality does
get worse but not phenomenally worse so
in this case quite a bit but here it's
not so much so that's the change in
quality by sampling just for our
algorithm this is a reconstruction error
because these are so topic vectors of
probability vectors so we measure the l1
distance okay the maximum distance
between two probability vectors is to
write the sum of absolute values is two
and you see that certain cases we are
almost set the maximum distance right
anyway so we do better on this then then
light le a time so this tells you what
kind of thing we used I'll give you the
time of the next slide right
so the times are here so our algorithm
without sampling is sometimes worse for
instance here it's what's here twist
right by which sampling and again we get
the results reported of its sampling
which sampling we are doing better in
time all on single box right the
implementations light Lda has a multi
box implementation as well we don't
refute and due out for our algorithm
because we we can do all of this in
single box so again this is time running
time again
as we go higher the sampling brings it
below the running time for light LD
Havers without sampling it is not so
these are possible improvements we are
thinking of one thing I want to back off
and say a little bit is there was always
this fear of SVD for very large matrices
partly we don't we don't have a real
barrier but the point is that it is one
of the ways one of the things to
demonstrate it here if in fact you can
do this we D on six billion a number of
non-zeros or four billion number of
non-zeros on a single box right we don't
do full SVD we only do the top 2,000
singular values and vectors that can in
fact be done that again is not rocket
science but it's just the fact that it
can be done to remember where we are
going so we are planning to improve the
k-means plus plus and also work for work
on a multi node implementation which can
scale up beyond this IC I have to read
the conclusion I didn't read it yet but
okay new topic one with large and so on
so forth
party time so we saw one more word about
pool with algorithms Sharma's also
mentioned this we do want algorithms
that scale up generally the
demonstration that they scale up is by
empirical verification empirical results
but I want to claim that proofs are
important because in fact we are going
to deal with big data we are going to
deal with large number of data sets and
if we don't prove our results the
benchmark results will not necessarily
carry everywhere right
so proofs are absolute and I would even
say there's a business reason because
you can tell your customers that I
absolutely guarantee this running time
in error bound okay and I think that's
all and new projects okay
okay yeah I think I'm done so let's see
I think we have one quick question
possibly it's not we can go to the next
stop
oh thank you
typically with the SVD okay okay
maybe one more question if you know the
subject of NFS and this non-negative
matrix factorization the there are many
algorithms so I'm wondering you pick the
LDA is there a reason to have unprovable
algorithm for nmf okay okay so those are
different this here game was only to the
topic modeling I guess I talk to you
offline okay yeah so it's a pleasure to
introduce Santosh Impala with our third
speaker Santosh has done many things
he's on the faculty at Georgia Tech
where he holds the story chair of
computer science he was a MIT earlier
and what he's going to talk about not
this two challenges in enough
I stepped out briefly and there are two
very exciting talks in the other
sessions if you want to rethink your
choice and some an array of cookies to
so please feel free but okay
here are two challenges and as advances
in theory so remains to see if they're
actually challenges let's see if you
agree or disagree so the first is the
robust model estimation so we saw in the
first two talk several excellent models
for data and what happens is small
fraction of the data is not from the
model even something as simple as PC you
can totally break down can we hope to
recover from that
proving this is work with a new brow and
given life and then of course the the
large mammal on the planet what can you
say probably about deep learning and you
know starting clear what the form of
such a guarantee would be given
especially a number of lower bounds and
even perhaps even more relevant this can
we say that stochastic gradient descent
probably works in some interesting set
of conditions and what if the data is
realizable you know it's actually coming
from a neural net what about that case
ok this will be Joe work with Liz song
John Wilson bullshi all right going back
to the first classical estimation
problems so we have data coming from
some distribution so in this example
it's a Gaussian whose parameters we
don't know I would like to estimate its
mean and variance so plus we know this
the foundations of statistics and in
this case just the sample mean and
sample variance are excellent estimators
it's optimal in some sense in the
precise sense and more generally the
maximum likelihood estimator converges
Fisher realized this and works proved it
but then back not that many years ago
now 50 years ago to kiosk what if there
are errors in the model so what does
that mean what if your data is not
exactly from a Gaussian or some other
distribution whose paramedics would like
to learn but
rather there's some noise that's been
introduced to it that you're not aware
of you don't have a nice model for the
noise it's actually noise can you still
accurately estimate the parameters of
this of the underlying ground data set
it's easy to motivate it some very
practical things so so I'll leave that
out here's another version what if your
data is from a mixture of two unknown
gaussian standard classical model again
Pearson's model and one question being a
mainstay of statistics and over the past
couple of decades in computer science is
can you estimate all the parameters of
two gaussians all you know that it's a
mixture of sugars and the answer is yes
in fact to fight us to match just the
first six moments this was already known
in 1d but even in higher dimension now
you can do it with time that's a
polynomial for any fixed number of
thousands but now the question you want
to ask here is what if the data is not
exactly from mm there's been some nice
that's introduced okay so one can ask
this question in many ways but let me
also give you a maybe from an algorithm
point of view PCA is used everywhere a
clustering mixtures optimization
supervised learning independent
component analysis and so on you project
to the top K components as we saw so in
very stock but what if the data is
corrupted the data is what you really
want to topics off or or the components
off plus a little bit 1% of arbitrary
noise in this case just keep ones you
don't even need 1% constant number of
points can destroy the entire piece here
we'd still like to estimate the original
unknown covariance matrix because that's
what has it done ok so this is the
question what about errors in the model
itself now I have to tell you what what
K what are we arguing what the noise
basically nothing only how much noise a
bound on the amount of noise so we would
like to assume that some bounded
fraction of the data is noise say is
let's talk it's a de 8 a fraction of the
data is noise moreover this noise is
introduced after looking at the data
so imagine there's data that's clean and
pure it's not
somebody is obliviously generating noise
they know your model they know your data
and then they get to add an eight a
fraction to destroy it whatever they
want so it really is worst case noise
it's a variant of what in statistics is
hoover's contamination model so again so
the data fraction of points added to the
sample and now you'd like to estimate
the mean and covariance of the original
distribution without did okay so more
precisely what is estimate mean you'd
like to find the mean and covariance
that are as close as possible in a
suitable norm in this talk I'll just
stick to the Euclidean norm now so this
even this statement of the problem has
several direct applications find the
best fit distribution that's more or
less the signal problem robust pca
because if you estimate the covariance
matrix agnostically you can then run a
standard pca on that robust independent
component analysis that takes some work
but there are existing algorithms for
which you could plug in a robot's
estimated robust hidden Markov models
and so on okay now there are of course
limits you can't you know if your noise
is loud you know if you shouldn't be
able to recover anything about the
originator what exactly are they so it's
going back to just the Gaussian if the
true distribution is just a 1d Gaussian
the best you can estimate the best
accuracy which you can estimate the mean
is 1/8 are the noise fraction multiple
of the standard deviation Sigma Y
because 1/8 a fraction of the data can
move the mean by 8 a sigma right so see
if you have some Gaussian and I want to
move the mean by by some distance when I
get to move at a fraction of the data
and move it by 8 a sigma so you can't
tell the difference between the original
distribution and the one which you
shifted absolutely no difference could
have been either one could have been the
original the true distribution so the
best error you can afford to have you
can guaranteed is it a signal even in
summation theoretically
okay so so that's that that will be
great to achieve we'd like to get this
optimal error in in polynomial time
probably
so first guess of course let's use the
empirical mean and covariance they work
great for for without noise no
they of course don't work one point is
enough to destroy this this is something
we all know the mean is destroyed can
disturb the one point so what do you use
also something probably everybody's
familiar with you could use the median
okay in 1b or the median absolute
deviation to measure to estimate the
standard deviation and these work they
work to actually give you the APA Sigma
error now the thing is it's all nice in
one dimension we of course have data in
high dimension and what can you do then
so two natural ideas one of them is the
coordinate wise median just use the
median but the separate media in each
coordinate and that gives you an
n-dimensional estimator of the mean now
a very nice idea is the geometric median
which is the solution to this
optimization problem which is convex
which is to find the point Y which
minimizes the sum of the Euclidean
distances to the data set not the square
just Euclidean it's in this if you put
the square there he will get back just
the centroid which the empirical mean
and that's uses but in the sum of
distances this has applications on its
own now the trouble is that both of
these estimators in the worst case give
you not eight a sigma but eight a sigma
square root n so the error they are
these these methods estimators would
incur gross polynomially of the
dimension that's just what they're going
to do on the other hand the lower bound
is still only eight a sigma in fact if
you allowed exponential time you can get
an estimator that whose error is only
eight a sigma so that's the gap right
bridge and to put it up there there are
methods we I already mentioned geometric
waiting there's something called the two
comedian it has to do with her
nice generalization of the median which
gives you the data
I dropped the Sigma term you see the
eight are optimal error of the constant
but it's sending hard to compute there
are other methods which either take
exponential time or give you large
dependence on the fact this was the
state of the eye okay so here's what one
can do let's generalize it not gaussians
but any
situation where the fourth moment is not
too much larger than the second moment
squared so the ratio that the error
guarantee depends on this parameter in
fact it's essential you can't avoid it
so I'm calling that number C for year so
for example sub Gaussian Exponential's
Gaussian distributions with bounded
fourth moments all of these things fit
here and this is in high dimension as
long as you have this that the fourth
moment is not is you know how much not
you'll need to know but but but your
error will depend on that in this
setting you still have information
theoretic lower bounds they are slightly
worse so if instead of Gaussian because
ETA Sigma you assume only the fourth
moment condition then the best estimator
you can have is not at a Sigma but a tie
to the 3/4 Sigma there just is one the
example already tells you that put your
data
I've - Sigma Sigma and a tiny 8 a
fraction of it is significantly further
away and your best estimator is is off
by a 2 3 4 3 so that's that's the best
you can do because it could have been
either distribution with or without
noise and can tell the difference ok so
here the here's what you can do so you
can achieve 800 3/4 Sigma with a square
root log n factor moreover if this is in
the case where you know that the
covariance and moreover the sample
complexity is essentially optimal it's
linear in the dimension and over the
error square if you don't know the
covariance then you can get a tie to the
square root and then Sigma x squared log
n the lower bound is still only 3/4 so
it's slightly often a ton still but
nevertheless it's only root log N and
the sample complexity is still only
linear in the damage you can also
estimate the covariance so you don't you
know not only the mean this is just a
simple trick of thinking of the Co
variance estimation itself has a mean
estimation problem in a product space
and in this case the the factor is
square root 8 a log n times the 2 norm
so you see here the here on the Left we
have the Frobenius norm the entire error
of the covariance matrix and on the
right hand side it's the tuna so it's a
sharp guarantee and the sample
complexity is not quadratic in n okay
for this we need eight moments to be
bounded as well in terms of not just the
fourth candidate one okay concurrent
with our work was work by do curricular
comet kane lee mode science to it
appeared in the same conference they
actually get nearly optimal bounds for
some distributions including gaussian
they managed to replace the log in with
log 1 over 8 they encourage higher
sample complexity in some places but but
they've improved that since then yeah
and I'll mention more about their work
little later so here's the fourth normal
condition again going back to this
median does not work
even with even median doesn't work in 1d
it's because if you try to use median
here you're going to take either one
side or the other side that's so the
solution is to find the smallest
interval that contains 1 minus 8 a
fraction of the points rather than the
meeting smallest interval that contains
1 minus 8 of the factional points and
then take its centroid so that that
works in 1d so here's the main algorithm
so again we have I'm just going to
describe it for the Gaussian case but
you can apply for any of these
situations your true data has a gaussian
and you've added noise to it mu I'm
referring to as the original mean thing
you can think of it as zero if you want
and then mu s is the sample mean with
the noise now to estimate the mean of
course it suffice to know which
direction the mean shifted or how what
are the Bombers to the mean shift with
once you know that you subtract that in
your done okay so we'd like to estimate
the mean shift because of the noise so
because it wants us to make that you can
project orthogonal to that mean shift
and you recover your you know everything
else natural idea is the top principal
component will the top and snow
component recover the mean shift
direction and the answer is no you could
place your noise in such a way that that
it's not going to be this the mean shift
work so here's the algorithm just has
two steps the first step is going to be
a very weak outlier removal we're going
to get rid of points that could do a lot
of damage by turning our points outside
a large enough ellipsoid and the second
step maybe this is the interesting step
rather than doing principal
announcements where you directly go to
the top component we're going to project
the top half when someone's n over two
things new components
ignore the bottom half just the top half
and then recurse on that just recur
sonic the curse means I applied a move
followed by projection outline mode
followed by projection till you get down
to one dimension so the login iterations
that's the entire level
so again if the dimension is one we just
returned the median and other if attire
with this card points that are far away
and wide by far I mean Sigma times
square root n far away you can estimate
this just using the coordinated eyes
median and in the second step we compute
the top n over 2 eigen subspace
recursively compute the mean in this
subspace in the top and O 2 and for the
bottom in over 2 just append the sample
mean you think of those are the
coordinates or the top a little
substance or you recursively compute the
mean and the bottom no to just take the
sample mean attach it back here and I
mean here's a simulation here's the data
there's the outlier removal after that
you here is a projection if you
recovered the moonship structures but
that's the other ok and for the analysis
I'll just mention that it follows just
from this one equation writing down the
covariance matrix and the outlier
removal controls the contributions of
the noise and make sure to be the end
the top eigenvalue can can can go crazy
but the n over 2 is eigenvalue can't go
up much why because if it goes up it has
to affect the first in a little okay
that's control and then the second part
of the analysis is that when you do the
projection because you project the main
shift vector can't be too large
magnitude and in fact it's the total
error you incur is only a 2 square Sigma
squared since we do it log n times you
pick up the fact of log N and that gives
the guarantee I won't say Morrison have
to get to the second challenge but here
is a this is on my laptop what you see
here are the plots that the x-axis of
dimension the yellow line is a true
sample mean and that's going to have
some error to because there's the do
greater and the sample mean just based
on how many steps you're using and I
chose the number sample so that that's
flat there is like and then
there's the the orange line is the
geometry medial one would have thought
that state of the art before and you can
see the error goes up the dimension and
the blue line is the algorithm I just
described running in MATLAB in fact I
thought I had code for it up here or
maybe I deleted that slide ok so here's
an algorithm works for white class needs
only a linear number of samples for mean
estimation but quadratic so right now
for Co variance estimation you can if
you'd like to run it you can run it and
there's several questions the analysis
as far as we know the login that we have
in our algorithm is not height just we
don't know we're just saying log in
because log in equations it's not clear
that these errors can actually add up
dear colliculus at all have obtained
several nice results extensions to other
applications and tighter bounds there
but there's many problems you could do
this for topic models with noise and you
prove that you can control the error
because of the noise okay that's
challenge one question if you want
otherwise I'll move on to challenge two
which is what about deep learn so but
rudely obviously it works so lower
bounds by realizable I mean that the
data itself is being generated by a
network that that you know it's the
structure but of course not the weight
now from the theory perspective know
there are these extreme lower bounds
it's np-hard to train a network with
just three neurons two and one and this
was shown by Ivan Blum and John Lewis
and then if you make slightly stronger
assumptions and these are fairly
standard complexity crypto assumptions
you cannot efficiently learn even small
depth to networks ok so again more
recently into the quite related to our
work even with very nice input
distributions some specific standard
deep learning algorithms will not work
on some families and I'll mention more
about it so in the face of this how do
we even formulate something now there
are some positive results they don't
quite address the problem I like videos
for example one can show that you can
linear dynamical systems through
gradient descent that for a single rare
value network with some special
structure convolution with non
overlapping sums can be done and then if
you use neural network training albums
that are not gradient descent maybe
tensor base or combinatorial for
specific models they do work approve
many did more samples but nevertheless
pollen isn't okay so here's a here's
what seems like a nice family of neural
networks right I mean nice meaning
simple this is what's generating the
data each input is just a Gaussian
standard Gaussian there are essentially
linear number of say sigmoid units with
weights that are nice and bounded
they're not too small or too large and
then there is a linear sum again that's
the data and this activation function is
not it's not even something like a
threshold which from which you can get a
lot of hardness results let's just say
it's smooth the Lipschitz in fact it's
something like that in this case we will
call it parameter F the sharpness of the
activation function and more generally
let's say each input is from some log
concave distribution of your choice it's
a lock on character solution may be a
uniform on an interval may be an
exponential whatever but but something
you know explicitly you choose the
activation function is any one of the
well-known ones that I'll describe the
general class and it's no view the data
is coming from this distribution
specifically and this gate and it's
small and then the output is a sum and
then you get to do what we want in the
training part you can use a fancy
network more layers more gates you know
some variant of gradient descent that
you'd like that I haven't get heard of
regularization etc okay and here's
basically the the low bound that if your
algorithm looks like it is based
querying some black box functions of the
input by input I mean both the input X
and of course the label Y or the output
Y XY pairs
it's evaluating some blackbox functions
then for example gradients you can think
of that as a black box function XY give
me back to ready doesn't matter if you
compute the variant or somebody else
increase the gradient and it's to within
accuracy one over s through ten s is
this sharpness parameter you could think
of it as a constant for now but the
point is the accurate is as small as 1
over root n then you need actually an
exponential number of such evaluations
that exists the family functions that
I'll describe explicitly in a minute for
which you need an exponential number of
such iterations no matter what black box
functions you will use ok let me try to
make this more precise but first if you
just had the special case of gaussians
and sigmoids better than algorithm that
will learn this under some additional
assumptions the weights in particular
has to be well conditioned so on
it's a tensor based algorithm it's not
gradient descent and then there is a
lower bound at least against you know
the most basic version of SGD with mean
squared loss and that lower bound is for
a non realizable data but but similar in
spirit so you want to mention that ok so
here's the here's the interpretation of
a lower bound again they are coming from
a log concave distribution that you know
you can and activation functions you
know you know their sharpness parameter
also you know exactly what them all you
don't know all the ways in the middle
layer that's it you know the output is
the sum and you get to run any algorithm
of this form you can estimate any
function you want on the current weights
and the data ok H so for example H could
be gradient or second order gradient or
so on and then you get to apply an
update of whatever value you want H is
just a bounded function that's it but
small H and Big H are the same thing
sorry
and then you that this is the new form
of the other ok so what exactly is the
guarantee then how can we state such a
guarantee we all know we don't have
explicit computational lower bounds for
even very very hard problems so here is
the form of a guarantee we think of
these algorithms as what are called
statistical query algorithms
which means that the algorithm is not
explicitly seeing the data or doesn't
need to see the data
it's just evaluating functions on the
data in particular it's evaluating
expectations of the data on a function
of its choice so example gradient and
until within some bounded error exactly
what let me just make this precise so if
there's a function f and if expectation
is P then this Oracle model it as an
Oracle leastat with a parameter T you
can choose returns the value P do with
an error smaller than 1 over T and
square root 3 times 1 minus P over T the
right hand side the simple way to think
about it it's just the bound the error
of the error if you are tossing T
Bernoulli coins T independent Bernoulli
coins that would be your inner 1 so it's
within the error of T independent or not
equines okay so if you are sampling you
would need T samples to get that with
constant probability
it's like saying T samples okay so if
this is what you could do but you get to
pick your function each time and your
function could be super hard to compute
doesn't matter but questions how many
iterations will it take then in this
framework you can capture basically all
known supervised and unsupervised full
the learning algorithms except Gaussian
elimination parity learning where that's
the only example we know that doesn't
sit in the framework and is efficient
and using the same framework there are
several tight lower bounds so tight
matching the upper bounds and
exponential in many cases for other
problems I won't have time to go into
these so in this framework here is the
precise statement of the theorem there
exists a family functions realized
completely at neural networks would say
a sigmoid layer but could be replace
that with anything you want so that any
statistical query learning algorithm
which learns this to it in error
slightly better than the concepts and
what a constant function will give you
needs exponential number of queries with
even if each each round uses basically
linear in the dimension number of
samples okay
and I said it works for other other
other sigmoids and so on
now let's conclude with the explicit
description of the family
so if it's sigmoid and all we do is we
take a combination of two sigmoids to
create a bump like that okay so it's
just a shifted X and minus X there and
then you you add several of them shift
so the biases are different you see the
buys a 0 2 over s minus 2 over s plus 2
over s minus 4 over X plus 4 over s and
so on so it's like a little wave it's
almost periodic it's not quite periodic
because we're going to stop between -
we're going to do it only in a bounded
range so the middle one will feel more
effect on the others it's lightly damped
periodic and of course it's bounded
that's the nature of this middle
construction and you could do that with
values for example compose two together
something that's more ionic and compose
for to get a bump and then you can come
out of the bump and here it's the
complete description so the the middle
layer is doing what we just said the
function is you're going to sum up an
unknown subset of the input and then
each of those second hidden layer units
is computing one of those biases so that
it's the shifted some that's it okay so
rather than feeding it a 1d input you're
feeding it it is still a one input but
it's a sum of a fixed subset of the N
variables ok but it's a smooth function
- completely explicit smooth function
let's assume ok so there has a function
and the size of subset of picked to be n
over two so there are of course
exponentially many choices for these
subsets and the point is that if you
didn't know which subset any two subsets
are highly uncorrelated if you can test
one subset and the two subsets might be
off by only a constant number of inputs
but if the effect of the function is
huge
it changes the function by a constant ok
now you can say ok that sounds great in
theory world war in practice generate
data from this network and try some of
the state of the art you know algorithms
which are now nicely available for
everybody to run I can run it on my
laptop or on a honor
cluster and this is what both she did
and so for example for the sigmoid you
see the training error point zero three
five there that's the that's that's the
what you get to the constant if I just
output constant all the time
you get that okay this is the expect the
x-axis is the s square root n the
sharpness parameter times square root n
so has the sharpness parameter those up
suddenly we go from basically zero error
to error which is I don't know how to do
better than that so if you have a way to
do better than this by your favorite
neuronal o'clock algorithm and be
trained and here is the here is a no
that's not special about sigmoid and
Gaussian here are three different
distributions Sigma's and relatives the
exactly the same function subset of n
over two edges and in all cases you're
hitting this special so to conclude what
can your networks learn efficiently I
don't know but a guess would be what if
the weight matrix is is generic or well
conditioned but really what real wise
structure makes them easy to learn
because it seems like they're doing well
in practice although we should be
careful you know if you didn't know max
flow algorithm we were short ass pattern
we were just trying to run say greedy it
might look good might look better and
what's been done before but maybe it's
not really working but other hand maybe
it is and we'd like to know why or maybe
a generic wait for something about the
nature of the input is making it close
to convex I don't know he'll stop this
thank you
[Applause]
what about the assumption about how the
input the X is generated yeah so in this
in the in the lower bound the input can
be any luck on case function of your
choice so for example each input
coordinate could be a Gaussian or could
be uniform and into yes but they're
independent independent yes yeah and in
fact they are very far from in the turn
good so in one of the plots you see the
last one there they're actually
generated from the uniform l1 ball so
there's a they are not independent I
mean they're not that far from being
independent but they're not expecially
independent but yeah it that could be a
the fact that input coordinates are
correlated maybe that's useful
thank you